a legal fight that's delayed absentee
ballots
in pennsylvania could be resolved by a
court as early as today
as election-related lawsuits play out
around the country
some voters may be confused about
deadlines and the process for absentee
ballots
in their states others might be wary of
the postal service or their own state's
ability
to handle the expected surge in volume
tony's been looking into your options
for returning your mail-in ballot tony
what did you learn
without the mail is the key part of it
so vote by mail is expected to play a
big role in this year's elections and
the u.s postal service does say it is
ready
it can handle the surge despite the
recent controversies over
overtime and those delays in processing
but many voters may take comfort in
knowing that there are
other options for returning your ballot
without the mail
so option number one local election
offices now almost
everywhere voters can return ballots at
these locations they tend to be county
or city clerk's offices option number
two
in-person voting locations there are at
least 11 states that allow you
to drop off ballots at places like early
voting sites
and as a bonus sometimes you can even
skip the line option number three
secure drop boxes you've probably heard
of these many states are setting up
these drop boxes
in public places like city buildings or
community centers and more states are
expected to add to this so
keep your eye out option number four may
surprise you somebody else yes most
states allow
someone other than you to return your
ballot for you
with restrictions in at least four
states you need an excuse like an
illness
and the rules vary about who can
actually handle your vote so depending
on where you live
it could be a spouse or a family member
or even a lawyer
even a nurse in some cases now there are
your four ways to use uh vote by mail
without using the mail so you'll get
your ballot in the mail but then you've
got four options for returning it
avoiding the postal service but people
also may be wondering
how can i check whether my mail-in vote
has actually been
counted the president recently suggested
that voters in north carolina
try to vote in person two as a check but
do not try this
knowingly voting more than once is
prohibited in every single state in our
union
many states though including north
carolina offer online tools to check
your ballot that is a good option
and of course you can always call your
local election board or secretary
of state's office for more information
and i recommend you do so because these
deadlines and these rules are always
changing and guys
i understand people's concern about the
usps
yes but they say they can handle this if
you give them at least seven days
they will get your ballot in on time
keep in mind they handle mother's day
they handle christmas christmas the vote
is nothing compared to those days yeah
in terms of yeah i love how north
carolina officials immediately
fact checked the president said to
people do not do this it's against the
law
so i hope people are paying attention to
that but it's good to know that there
are so many options i'm still thinking
on election day i'm going to suit up i
was going to mail but yeah
i'm going to suit up put everything on
gloves on and go and do it in person i
don't know
you know i don't know the restrictions
are here in new york but you know if you
receive your ballot you may be able to
sign a little form hand the ballot to me
and i'll walk it in for you yeah i'll be
your career i didn't actually get one oh
you got one yeah
but i still like either pulling a lever
or sticking a thing i don't know i still
like to do it yeah i
feel good i like that i like knowing
that once i've done that my vote is
it's been counted it's there but a lot
of people can't do it so that's why i
think
a lot of people are worried about it and
understanding we're worried about it
yeah